I'm dr. John Moses I'm climbing Wales's
highest mountain we're gonna head up
there and when we get to the top we're
going to make a molecule called sis
platinum
it's a inorganic complex and used
clinically to treat many forms of cancer
very successfully
well my group in what I thought we'd
have an adventure weekend and we thought
let's combine it with our passion of
chemistry and the outdoors and when we
get to the top of Snowdon we thought
let's do something quirky and make a
molecule to show how easy chemistry is
to do anyway
have lots of family members who've had
cancer been affected by cancer
my own mother passed away from cancer
and a lot of my research groups family
have been affected by cancer so I think
it's a worthy cause and it gives you
some inspiration to do the science well
we choose cisplatin because it's fairly
simple to make sort of it's rather
simple molecule and we can make it in
water and as you can see from this
weather that becomes a bonus
whereas lots of other organic molecules
sensitive to water so combining water
and chemistry is not always good can be
good fun
it was discovered in the mid 19th
century but became involved in cancer
therapy in the late 70s and it's been
very successful it just shows that
something quite simple can have a huge
effect on society so that's really why
we chose that molecule and also because
some of the organic natural product
based molecules are so complicated to
make and we probably here several weeks
making them so we can get to this
platinum out in a couple of hours
hopefully on maybe less chose Snowdon
because I'm Welsh from North Wales I
spent a lot of time up here as a young
man a young boy even and I love this
countryside and I wanted to take my
group up to somewhere which is very
familiar to me so it's quite personal to
me as it's a chemistry so we chose
Snowdon it's a great location
we're on top of Snowden the highest
point in Wales great a little bit cool
agree we're just setting up the
experiment and James and Sally as you
can see in the tent are setting up the
equipment ready to be up so they're
organized so they can get straight into
it and not fumble around and chemistry
in the clouds absolutely I think it's
the highest chemical reaction done in
Wales I'm guessing I don't think this
has ever been done before okay we're
making a molecule called sis platinum
it's an inorganic compound and here's a
structure of it were like in a model of
a human so there's the platinum the
metal at the center of the complex here
we have two chlorides and two ammonia
ligands so the chloride assists to each
other that means they the same side and
the ammonia to ammonia groups are also
on the same side and sis the same side
so and this is it's quite a simple
molecule square planar so the addition
of a saturated solution of potassium
right brilliant just proud of my
students know that they can do chemistry
in the most extreme environments very
uncomfortable oh that's pretty yeah
stony under it Cushing with this okay
wait because this is the hottest thing
we have a pair we want to speed the
reaction up a little bit maybe should
see the ammonia is displaced into the
chloride ligands quite generous
donations of some very nice people and a
lot of nice people have donated on our
website too so I've got to thank
everybody
yeah really really good okay so this is
the final compound here this is a
cisplatin and it's quite a lot of it as
well excellent you what's next well I
think we're gonna do stage two we're
gonna have to do some more chemistry
somewhere a bit more extreme maybe
higher up or maybe lower down let's see